donc rebonjour à ceux qui étaient là ce
matin et bonjour à ceux qui n'étaient
pas on reçoit sa qualité de président du
Haut Conseil des finances publiques
Monsieur Pierre Moscovici a habitué de
la maison afin qu'ils nous présente la
vie qui a rendu le Haut conseil sur le
projet de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 qui a été
rendu public ce lundi 23 janvier au
dépôt du projet de loi sur le bureau de
l'Assemblée nationale je rappelle
conformément au 5 de l'article 61 de la
Love le Haut Conseil est chargé
d'émettre un avis sur les prévisions
macroéconomiques gouvernement retient
pour l'élaboration du projet de loi de
finances rectificative de la sécurité
sociale et sur la cohérence de ce projet
notamment dans son article luminaire on
regarde des orientations plus réelles de
sol de structurel fixées par le mode
programmation par ailleurs c'est une
innovation la loi organique du 28
décembre 2021 qu'il est important de
mentionner le Haut Conseil doit
également donner son avis sur le
réalisme des prévisions de recettes et
dépenses du PLFSS c'est comme c'est par
le PLFSS
que passe cette réforme de retraite il
était donc naturel que le président du
Haut Conseil et la parole et je lui
donne tout de suite
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
rapporteur général mesdames et messieurs
les députés merci de m'avoir invité donc
cet après-midi puisque mon corrigé
devant votre commission en tant que
président du conseil et finances
publiques pour vous présenter les
principales conclusions de notre avis
relatif aux projets de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale
plfrss pour 2023
permettez-moi d'abord de vous présenter
mes meilleurs vœux car c'est vrai que je
me suis habitué à la maison je suis venu
depuis le début de l'année mais à côté
la Commission des verses sociales pas
encore à la commission des finances et
de vous dire tout le plaisir que j'ai
d'être là aujourd'hui devant vous et je
sais que j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir
plusieurs reprises pendant l'année qui
vient je vais commencer par un rappel
d'émission du Haut Conseil qui était
saisie en l'occurrence en application
l'article 61 de la loi du 1er août 2001
relative aux lois de finance modifiées
car il permet de mieux appréhender le
contenu de notre avis le Conseil est
appelé de donner une triple appréciation
sur le projet de loi de financement
rectificative de la sécurité sociale
pour 2023 qui faisait soumis d'une part
sur les prévisions macrones économiques
sur lequel il repose d'autre part sur le
réalisme des prévisions de recettes
dépenses enfin le gouvernement a demandé
où acheter de se prononcer sur la
cohérence de son article liminaire au
regard des orientations pluriannuelles
de sols structurelles administrations
publiques définies dans le projet de loi
programmation des finances publiques
regardez mission du Haut Conseil des
finances publiques dont le rôle vous le
savez et d'apprécier le réaliste des
prévisions macroéconomiques et de
finances publiques des textes financiers
le hcfp a estimé première remarque que
la saisine du gouvernement était
particulièrement étroite en effet le
gouvernement n'a saisi le hcfp que sur
l'incidence de la réforme sur les
finances publiques pour la seule année
2023 au delà il ne nous a transmis que
les informations très partielles
en termes d'horizon 2026 en termes de
champs il s'agit des comptes des seuls
régimes de base et du FSV et non de
l'ensemble des administrations publiques
et d'explications sur les chiffrages et
les différents dispositifs le Conseil
n'a donc pas été en mesure
d'évaluer l'incidence de moyens termes
de la réforme
des retraites sur les finances publiques
et c'est un prisme manuel qui évidemment
très regrettable au regard des
conséquences d'une telle réforme qui
s'est en nécessairement pour sa part sur
le moyen et long terme et la nécessité
de l'expertise indépendante que peut
offrir le Conseil j'en viens maintenant
cette remarque tout de même importante
est en fait sur nos deux principaux
messages relatifs au
plrss premier message le scénario
macroéconomique du gouvernement pour
2023 paraît toujours optimiste même si à
ce stade dernières informations
disponibles sur les comics françaises
montrent une résilience plus forte que
prévu ce dont je me réjouis comme vous
tous deuxième message la réforme des
retraites aura un impact très faible sur
les finances publiques en 2023 le hcfp
n'a pas en revanche pu estimer les
conséquences de moyens termes sur les
finances publiques faute de disposer des
informations suffisantes de la part du
gouvernement permettez-moi d'abord
d'évoquer brièvement ces deux messages
compléteraient cette présentation par
quelques remarques sur la situation
générale des finances publiques de notre
pays je vais commencer par l'analyse de
la situation macroéconique le
gouvernement comme vous l'avez remarqué
n'a pas modifié son scénario
macroéconomique par rapport au projet de
loi de finance et de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale pour 2023 qui
date donc de septembre dernier pour 2023
le gouvernement continue de prévoir un
rythme de croissance du Pipe de un point
dans son avis sur le projet de loi
finance et le projet de loi de
financement la sécurité sociale pour
2023 le Conseil avait alors estimé que
ces prévisions étaient un peu élevées du
fait de plusieurs hypothèses que nous
considérions comme fragile en outre les
informations conjoncturelles récentes
laissent à penser je crois que chacun le
constate que la croissance est
essoufflée en fin d'année 2022
notamment
en raison de l'impact de l'inflation et
de la hausse des taux d'intérêt sur la
demande des ménages des entreprises la
prévision de 1% du gouvernement pour
2023 suppose par conséquent une
accélération nette de l'activité au
cours de l'année ce qui à première vue
semble un peu contre-intuitif
cette hypothèse ne peut toutefois pas
être exclu même si ce n'est pas la plus
probable compte tenu des récents signaux
positifs montrant une certaine
résilience de l'économie française
l'emploi demeure pour le moment
dynamique le risque une rupture des
approvisionnements en électricité gaz
par est désormais limité pour les
prochains mois l'hiver est relativement
clément les tensions sur les prix de
l'énergie satellite puis l'été et le
ralentissement de l'économie allemande
et plus généralement de la zone euro
apparaît moins prononcé quantité au
début de l'automne notamment notre
voisin allemand devrait pouvoir c'est
aussi une bonne nouvelle pour nous
contenu de l'indétaire indépendance de
nos économie évitez la réception en 2023
ce qui n'était pas le consensus des
prévisionnistes il y a encore quelques
mois
le scénario de croissance ou grande
paraît toutefois encore optimiste car
l'environnement international demeure
mal orienté en 2023 alors même que le
durcissement des politiques monétaires
devraient poursuivre dans la zone euro
madame Lagarde n'a encore répété hier et
avant-hier et freiné la demande au cours
des prochains trimestres
l'investissement pourrait notamment
bâtir de la hausse plus forte anticipée
en septembre dernier des taux d'intérêt
dans la zone euro vous savez que la
Banque centrale européenne annonce des
hausses encore assez conséquente pour
les temps qui viennent dans un contexte
de refroidissement d'activité et
d'incertitude élevé de fait la prévision
de croissance du gouvernement se situe
au-dessus de l'ensemble des prévisions
des instituts conjonctuels tant en
français qu'internationaux ainsi que du
consensus des économistes qui en janvier
donc maintenant anticipe une croissance
économie française de seulement 0,2
points en 2023 je rappelle que la de
France elle dans ses imprévisions est à
0,3 donc un point c'est clairement au
dessus encore une fois pas exclu d'avoir
une bonne surprise le plus probable est
quand même que ce chiffre demeure élevé
et
s'il est élevé il faudra bien le
corriger le moment
le Conseil considère donc que la
prévision de croissance associée au
PLFSS reste élevé elle est justifiée par
le gouvernement par la résilience de
commis françaises au troisième trimestre
2022 par la quitte croissance sur 2023
pour nous elle sous-estime cependant les
facteurs de freinage l'activité
actuellement à l'oeuvre notamment le
niveau élevé de l'inflation et le
durcissement en cours des politiques
monétaires
le gouvernement prévoit également
toujours pour 2023 une hausse de
l'indice des prix à la consommation de
4,2% au moyen-elle annuel après une
progression de 5,2 en 2022
les prévisions d'inflation restent
dépendants de l'évolution des prix
énergétiques qu'il est aujourd'hui très
difficile d'anticiper la fin de la
remise carburant ou 31 décembre 2022 la
revalorisation de 15% en moyenne des
tarifs réglementés du gaz au 1er janvier
de l'électricité au 1er février sont à
court terme plutôt des facteurs de
hausse alors que les baisses récentes
des primes des marchés du gaz et du
Pétrole auront à l'inverse un effet
baissier
disons que nous avons estimé que le
reflux anticipé par le gouvernement de
l'inflation semble néanmoins rapides
cette prévision d'inflation pour 2023
est en effet plus faible que la moyenne
du consensus des économistes cette
moyenne s'établit à 4,8 % 4,2 % la prise
de commande et ça suppose en est
infléchissement par rapport aux
tendances récentes or l'indexation du
SMIC les hausses de salaire déjà
négociées ainsi que la transmission en
cours des hausses passées des prix de
production et d'importation au prix des
produits alimentaires devraient
continuer à soutenir l'inflation en 2023
au vu de l'ensemble de ces éléments le
Conseil considère que la prévision
d'inflation retenue pour 2023 est un peu
faible donc croissance un peu élevée
inflation un peu faible le gouvernement
a également maintenu sa prévision d'une
progression de la masse salariale des
branches marchandes non agricole de 5
points 2023
cependant cette prévision paraît faible
notamment en lien avec la
sous-estimation des perspectives de la
relation nous ne sommes pas dans une
boucle priscillaire mais tout de même il
y a des mécanismes qui font que quand
l'inflation est plus élevée la hausse
des salaires pourrait l'être également
davantage le Conseil estime donc que la
prévision de masse salariale pour 2023
un peu basse je résume cette première
partie sur les prévisions
macroéconomiques
le Conseil estime que la prison
croissance pour 2023 encore élevé même
si on ne peut pas exclure de bonnes
surprises en revanche la prévision
d'inflation est un peu basse comme celle
de la masse salariale j'entre maintenant
dans le détail si je peux dire des
constats du HCP les finances publiques
sur la base de cette saisine que nous
jugeons je le répète trop étroite je
rappelle que le mandat du hcfp d'évaluer
le réalisme des recettes et des dépenses
du PLF RSS qui vous est présenté et de
veiller à cohérence de ce texte avec les
orientations plus réelles de finances
publiques
sur ce dernier point la loi organique ne
permet pas au hcfp de se prononcer car
le projet de LPF présenté par le
gouvernement n'a à ce stade pas été
adopté
ceci me donne l'occasion d'insister sur
un message que j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de présenter au Parlement d'abord devant
vous-même un instigation de votre
rapporteur général qui m'avait interrogé
et que le HCP reprend dans son avis la
France ne peut pas mesdames et messieurs
les députés se passer d'une loi de
programmation de finance publique c'est
une obligation juridique c'est une
obligation organique c'est une
obligation européenne c'est surtout un
instrument de pilotage indispensable des
finances publiques l'érosion progressive
de la position de finances publiques de
la France au sein de la zone euro les
investissements publics massifs auxquels
notre pays fait face nécessite de
redresser nos comptes publics pour y
parvenir et je crois que c'est
indéniable sans retour sans recours à
l'austérité comme le monde de nombreux
exemples européens l'effort doit
évidemment être piloté sur plusieurs
années pour être réaliste et pour
préserver le potentiel de croissance de
l'économie
c'est pourquoi nous avons besoin nous
collectivement le pays d'une telle
programmation plus réelle
son absence pose de nombreux problèmes
tant juridique à la fois au regard de
notre droit interne qu'on regarde du
traité sur la stabilité la croissance et
la gestion européenne tant pour le
travail du Haut conseil que pour celui
de la Commission européenne et nous
sommes toujours sous le regard du
Conseil constitutionnel ne sous-estimez
pas mesdames et messieurs les députés
les risques d'une telle absence nous
pourrions entrer dans un processus de
finance publique qui serait discontinue
et incomplet c'est donc pas une bricole
c'est pas une anecdote c'est un vrai
sujet et je me permets de la place qui
est la mienne d'appeler toutes les
parties prenantes à faire en sorte que
la France se dote d'une telle
programmation et c'est ce dès que
possible son absence est hautement
préjudiciable
s'agissons du réalisme des dépenses et
des recettes présentées dans le bel
effet SS comme j'ai déjà indiqué le
gouvernement n'a transmis au HCP que les
impacts de la réforme des retraites
concernant l'année 2023 et quelques
éléments généraux peu détailler jusqu'à
les constates du hcfp dans ce contexte
des trois tests sont les suivants
les conséquences du projet de réforme
des retraites sur les finances publiques
en 2023 sont faibles avec un coût je dis
bien un coup estimé par le gouvernement
à 0,4 milliards d'euros estimation que
nous jugeons réaliste
ce coup de la réforme sur 203 résulte
d'une part des économies réalisées par
le décalage de trois mois du départ en
retraite d'environ 50000 personnes en
fin de 23 des recettes fiscales et des
cotisations sociales supplémentaires
liées à leur maintien dans l'emploi
pendant ces trois mois d'autre part des
dépenses supplémentaires entraîné par la
réforme qui sont notamment la hausse du
minimum contributif dont les conditions
précises restent toutefois déterminées
des mesures sur la pénibilité l'usure
professionnelle et des mesures en faveur
des transitions emploi retraite donc 400
millions de coups pourquoi parce que le
coût des mesures va plus vite que les
moindres dépenses ou les recettes
générées par l'implantation de la
retraite seulement de réforme seulement
en fin d'année plus largement s'agissant
du sol de public qui est prévu à 5
points de PIB en 2023 vous souvenez
peut-être que le HCF avait estimé en
septembre qu'il existait des risques le
déficit soit plus dégradé que prévu
devant vous je disais qu'il était
possible sinon probable qu'il y ait un
peu moins de 5 ans 2022 un peu plus en
2023 à ce jour le risque pour 2023 il y
a une croissance plus faible demeure
mais il est contrebalancé par la baisse
récente des prix de gros du gaz
électricité qui si elle se confirme pour
alléger le coût de l'ensemble des
dispositifs de soutien au ménage aux
entreprises donc il n'est pas exclu
qu'il y ait une bonne surprise que le
déficit finalement il peut être
légèrement supérieur à 5 il peut être à
5 il pourrait même être légèrement en
dessous ça c'est encore dans
l'incertitude
disons que ça vient contrebalancer c'est
le mot que nous utilisons le message que
je faisais passer devant vous en
septembre
des impacts de plus long terme sur les
finances publiques qui sont pourtant le
cœur de la réforme des retraites le hcfp
n'a pas eu d'information suffisante pour
lui permettre d'évaluer l'incidence de
la réforme à moyen terme ce qui
regrettable tout au plus a-t-il reçu
l'annexe au pellet RSS portant sur la
période 2023-2026 c'est difficile à
comprendre parce que nos finances
publiques ont besoin d'une gouvernance
transparente et d'une expertise
indépendante plus qu'une expertise
puisque le passage devant le HCP est une
exigence prévue par la loi organique de
2012 nous ont toutefois un diagnostic
qui pourrait vous intéresser qui est que
la réforme des retraites présente dans
ce bel effet SS ne devrait pas améliorer
la trajectoire de dette qui avait
présenté le gouvernement dans le projet
de LPFP en septembre
ça ne veut pas dire que il n'y a pas
d'impact sur la dette simplement ce
qu'il vous avait été soumis et ce qui
nous avait été soumis en septembre
incluait déjà une réforme des retraites
dont le HCP n'a pas eu les détails
disons que par rapport à ce qui était
prévu en septembre il n'y a pas
d'ambition supplémentaire dans l'effort
de redressement des dépenses publiques
alors même que nous avions estimé à
l'époque que la LPFP était peu
ambitieuse car nous pensions et je pense
toujours que l'inflexion visée de la
trajectoire de dette était limitée
en 2027 comme par hasard alors même que
les hypothèses de croissance était
plutôt optimistes et je vous rappelle
que nous sommes dans une situation où si
ces objectifs étaient suivis la plupart
des pays de la zone euro passerait en
dessous de 3% en 2025 en 2027 et tous
commencent à réduire leur trajectoire de
dès maintenant les données fournies au
Conseil permettent de constater que les
déficits des régimes de base de la
sécurité sociale du SSV sur la période
2023 du 26 sur désormais un peu plus
élevé dans ce bel effet SS que dans la
LFSS initiale pour 2023 les dépenses de
retraite autrement dit progressent dans
le présent projet de loi plus rapidement
que ce qui est très prévu en septembre
une telle évaluation est clairement le
résultat de l'intégration dans la
réforme des retraites deux mesures qui
n'étaient pas alors envisagées lors de
la présentation du projet de LPF qui
entraîne légère dégradation relative des
comptes publics par rapport à ce qui
était prévu en septembre
je voudrais enfin terminer sur
l'importance d'une réforme des retraites
je ne dis pas la réforme des retraites
parce que il n'appartient pas aux
présidents du HFP ni au premier
président de la Cour des comptes de
telle terminée son contenu ses contours
sont calendrier ces modalités
d'accompagnement de compensation ça
c'est la responsabilité du gouvernement
et du Parlement lien avec le partenaire
sociaux nous entendons en rien nous
substituer aux politiques en revanche
nous sommes là pour examiner la question
la soutenabilité des finances publiques
et nous constatons c'est notre point de
vue que en l'état le système n'est pas
finançable n'est pas soutenable et donc
il faut bien une réforme c'est pas à
nous de choisir les modalités
nous savons tous que nos finances
publiques ont connu j'ai utilisé ce mot
je le réutilise une érosion progressive
sur longue période et qu'elles n'ont pas
aujourd'hui les marges de manœuvre pour
faire face au choc et aux
investissements publics dans le pays a
besoin je ne veux pas jouer les
Cassandre d'autres l'ont trop fait et
non pas été entendus les mois simplement
rappeler quelques éléments factuels la
France est entrée dans la zone euro avec
un ratio de dettes dans la moyenne
européenne exactement équivalent à celui
de l'Allemagne au moment de l'entrée
dans la zone euro il se trouve que
j'étais à l'époque ministre des affaires
européennes souviens c'est en 2000 2001
nous étions à 58 points de dettes pour
l'Allemagne comme pour la France à
l'époque on disait que c'était
l'Allemagne l'homme malade de l'Europe
20 ans plus tard notre position relative
c'est nettement dégradé la dette de la
Belgique qui était très élevée pour le
coup augmenter d'un point celle de
l'Allemagne augmentait de 10 points
celle de l'Italie qui était aussi très
dégradée déjà de 41 points c'est de la
France a augmenté de 55 points 45 points
de plus que notre partenaire allemand
c'est un fait il faut en partir après
vous pouvez en déduire des conclusions
extrêmement différentes mais c'est un
fait robuste or la dette n'est plus
gratuite nous sommes sortis de l'air des
taux d'intérêt négatifs que certains
jugeaient bénis le taux d'intérêt à 10
ans à retrouver son niveau d'il y a 10
ans la charge de la dette en
comptabilité nationale représentait 30
milliards en 2020 35 milliards en 2021
elle est projetée à 44 milliards par le
gouvernement 2023 je vous rappelle
que le budget de la défense je ne compte
pas encore la loi de programmation
deuxième budget de l'État et tu as 41
milliards hors pension 50 pensions
inclus nous arrivons dans cette zone
dangereuse ou c'est le remboursement de
la dette qui devient du GEM budget de
l'État il n'y a pas
de charge ou de dépenses plus stérile
que la charge de la dette tout euro que
nous y consacrons dans un système de
taux d'intérêt positif est un euro en
moins pour les dépenses que les uns ou
les autres vous pouvez souhaiter pour le
pays qu'il s'agisse de la sécurité
sociale de l'éducation de lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique des dépenses
militaires c'est un euro perdu en vérité
pourquoi est-ce un problème parce que la
France fait face à des besoins
d'investissement public majeur et ce dès
aujourd'hui il faut pas s'y tromper
c'est aujourd'hui et nos deux mains que
la France doit rénover son système de
santé son système scolaire son armée
produire sur son territoire des biens
essentiels investir dans la recherche de
développement pour se maintenir dans la
compétition mondiale il y a des sujets
sur lesquels on voit bien qu'il y a des
retards qui viennent préoccupants
pensons par exemple à la santé
investir dans ses bras structures pour
s'adapter au changement climatique
réduire les émissions de CO2 il y a
devant nous un mur d'investissement
si un mur d'investissement est montagne
de dettes on a un vrai problème il faut
quand même rétablir un moment donné une
sorte de système de base communicant
pour financer les investissements en
ayant moins d'aide sans quoi nous
n'avons pas de marge de manœuvre
réformer les retraites quand c'est pas à
moi de dire comment
fait partie de l'effort collectif
nécessaire pour y parvenir mais ça ne
suffit pas la France a la capacité
d'améliorer ses comptes publics dans
tous les secteurs des politiques
publiques en recherchant la qualité de
la dépense c'est pas chose facile mais
nous ne le faisons pas alors que de la
plupart de nos partenaires le font une
revue annuelle de dépenses comme
l'annoncer le ministre des comédies
finances est nécessaire je salue cela la
Cour des comptes à mon initiative il
appelle depuis plusieurs années mais
attention une revue de dépenses doit
avoir une raison d'être une gouvernance
un calendrier une méthode des objectifs
clairs
voilà Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
nous sommes quand même dans des temps
compliqués qui nous appellent à un
esprit qui soit à la fois de sérieux
d'ambition c'est vrai aussi en matière
budgétaire je ne voudrais pas que ce
soit un accident qui nous oblige tout à
coup un rectifier notre trajectoire ce
qui voudrait dire couper drastiquement
dans les dépenses ou relever brutalement
les impôts
la Grande-Bretagne n'est pas un pays de
la zone euro ce n'est pas un petit pays
toutefois et je pense que ce qui s'est
passé toi quand même faire réfléchir
rien de tout cela ne serait dans
l'intérêt de notre pays voilà mes
messieurs les parlementaires mais c'est
le députés mesdames les principales
observations que je souhaitais partager
avec vous et on vous remercions de votre
attention je me tiens avec ceux qui
m'entourent que je remercie pour leur
travail parce que le Haut conseil c'est
une toute petite équipe même si grâce à
vous elle est un peu plus fournie qu'il
y a deux ans les mêmes doubler mais
enfin
on est passé de 3,5 emploi c'est ça
Eric qui travaille très bien très vite
dans des conditions pas toujours simples
avec des informations parfois lacunaire
et qui néanmoins réussissent à faire de
petits miracles je voulais les en
remercier devant vous et il
m'accompagneront pour les réponses à vos
questions ou interventions avec
pardonnez-moi d'avance
finalement tout un tas de sujet sur
lequel je pourrais pas vous répondre car
je ne vais pas me mettre à improviser
sur des informations que je n'ai pas
bien merci monsieur le Président
on va commencer par un trio que je vais
ouvrir et après c'est Marina Ferrari qui
interviendra puisqu'elle est rapporteur
pour avis sur le plfs P plafrss pardon
dont je rappelle qu'on l'examinera
vendredi dans la commission évidemment
Jean-René Cazeneuve rapporteur général
plusieurs
réflexions qui impliquent certainement
quelques réactions de votre part
la première sur je vais peut-être
commencer par par le fin de votre exposé
sur
sur la question un peu de ce que je
résumerai comme une quadrature du cercle
que vous présentez c'est à dire à la
fois le fait de reconnaître qu'on a un
mur d'investissement de nous
le chef de l'État vient d'en dévoquer
une eau un nouveau avec la question de
l'investissement massif
dans dans le système de défense mais on
sait également que on est très loin du
compte dans ce qui serait nécessaire en
termes de planification écologique et de
services publics et puis à la fois vous
dites que il y a ce mur d'investissement
mais il y a aussi la charge de la dette
et que quelque part la charge de la
dette est plus importante très
franchement il faudra qu'on m'explique
comment à un moment donné et c'est là où
je pense que mais c'est votre fonction
donc je vous le reproche pas mais notre
discours modifie on priorise soit les
investissements soit effectivement le
fait de s'endetter je ne vois pas
comment on fait des investissements à
long terme sans s'endetter et je pense
que notre économie peut le supporter
mais il y a une chose en tout cas
que notre économie peut pas supporter
c'est la baisse continue des dépenses
fiscales c'est à dire que à partir du
moment où il y a toujours moins de
rentrée fiscale
il y a un moment donné où c'est comme un
jeu de bonneto aussi il faut des
investissements si on dit qu'il faut
baisser la dette bien les chercher
quelque part alors vous dites la réponse
que fait le gouvernement et c'est là où
j'en viens un peu à votre rapport c'est
finalement il y a des baisses qui sont à
prévoir du côté d'autres dépenses
publiques voire de mécanisme de
solidarité et pourquoi pas celui des
retraites c'est ce que j'entends et
c'est d'ailleurs un peu ce qui nous a
été présenté alors moi je voudrais dire
que en préambule je pense que ce n'est
pas au système de retraite de payer les
déficits de l'État voilà c'est ce que je
pense moi je suis pour je suis assez
vieux jeu je pense que je suis pour un
système de retraite qui soit adossé aux
revenus
productions de richesse dû au travail et
quand je dis des productions de richesse
duo-trail j'implique le capital parce
que sauf
démonstration inverse il n'y aurait pas
de dividende il n'y aurait pas de
revenus du capital sans que du travail
produise la richesse
à partir de là je crois que la question
des de rechercher comment on équilibre
l'origine des retraites il est à
chercher plus vraisemblablement du côté
de nouvelles ressources et de nouvelles
ressources qui sont notamment des
ressources adossées aux revenus du
capital je note d'ailleurs que l'autre
jour le président du corps a dit une
chose je vous le rappelle ici je sais
que ça a fait réagir depuis mais que les
dépenses de retraite ne dérapent pas et
ne sont même à son même annoncées
baissantes dans trois des quatre
scénarios qu'il présente dans les années
à venir et que ce qui explique les
déficit ce qui explique les pourcentages
du PIB mais très franchement n'importe
quelle économie sérieux ne prend que le
pourcentage du PIB et pas des francs
courants quoi donc à partir des euros
courants donc à partir de là
la question et les ressources et donc on
est bien sur une question de recherche
de ressources et moi j'affirme que c'est
pas
c'est pas ça c'est pas il faut pas aller
chercher dans le régime de retraite de
quoi réduire les déficits d'État et
d'ailleurs j'observe en même en plus que
vous dites une phrase qui à mon avis est
tout aussi importante que la phase les
phrases du président du corps vous dites
que pour 2023 le projet de retraite sur
les finances publiques ça va être un
coup net de l'ordre de 0,4 milliards
d'euros et que pour la suite le Haut
conseil n'est pas en mesure d'évaluer
l'incidence de moyen terme de la réforme
des retraites sur les finances publiques
donc ce qui est indiqué ici c'est que
même dans la roche même si on impute ce
que je ne ce pourquoi je ne suis pas
favorable à la réforme des retraites le
fait de abaisser les déficits publics et
bien vous dites vous-même qu'on n'est
pas capable aujourd'hui avec la réforme
qui est posée sur la table de dire ce
qu'il en sera et je note aussi que vous
vous avez affirmé ces taux de phrases
que en fonction de ce qu'on connaît ça
ne devrait ça ne devrait pas diminuer la
trajectoire de la dette dans les années
à venir c'est ce que vous avez dit ici
bon donc voilà donc pour ce que je note
autre chose qui m'intéresse dans votre
intervention
c'est que vous rappelez vous l'avez déjà
vous avez cette constance là que entre
les prévisions à peu près toutes les
institutions économiques alors j'ai
regardé dans votre tableau elles sont de
elle varie en gros de moins excusez-moi
de moins 0,2 pour excès code à 0 + 0,7
pour le FMI au moyen on va dire qu'on
est à entre 0,3 04 pour l'an prochain
vous vous rappelez que avec 1% de
croissance estimée par le gouvernement
là aussi il y a quand même un problème
une problématique sur lequel s'appuie ce
projet de loosfinance de sécurité
sécurité sociale
rectificatif donc j'ai une question à
vous poser par rapport à
cet ensemble de de réflexion je me fais
c'est que
sur le caractère incomplet des
informations transmises par le
gouvernement qui ne vous permet pas
d'évaluer l'incidence mais interne de la
femme de retraite est-ce que vous pouvez
nous préciser qui sont les principaux
éléments d'information qui vous ont fait
défaut
pour procéder à une telle évaluation
voilà pour ma part et je passe la parole
à Marina Ferrari
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
notre commission qui m'a nommé
rapporteur pour avis sur le projet de
loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 porte une
attention toute particulière aux
incidences budgétaires du texte qu'elle
soit de cours ou de moyen terme la vie
du Haut Conseil des finances publiques
sur ce projet de loi de financement
rectificative monsieur le Président
m'inspire trois remarques principales
tout d'abord nous pouvons dire dans
votre avis que le Haut Conseil relève
que l'absence d'adoption du projet de
loi de programmation de finances
publiques ne lui permet pas de vérifier
la cohérence des prévisions des finances
publiques des textes financiers que la
loi de programmation et que cette
absence contraire aux engagements
européens de la France prive les
finances publiques d'une boussole
indispensable à leur bonne gestion et à
la préservation de la soutenabilité de
la dette publique il me semblait
important de souligner ce point comme
vous l'avez fait monsieur le Président
ce doté d'une loi de programmation est
un impératif pour notamment sécuriser
les expertises éclairer nos politiques
et écarter tout risque juridique vous
l'avez rappelé vous avez déclaré ce
matin en audition au Sénat qui écartait
une loi de programmation des finances
publiques est un exercice jugé
irresponsable je tenais à vous le
rappeler chers collègues étant donné la
teneur des bacs nous avons eu
précédemment ensuite votre avis souligne
l'obligation qui est la nôtre de
réformer notre système de retraite pour
assurer sa pérennité et participer aux
redressement de nos finances publiques
les prévisions du gouvernement se font
sur un scénario central d'un taux de
chômage de long terme de 4 et demi pour
cent et d'une croissance de la
productivité du travail de l'ordre de
1%. le Conseil considère que cette
dernière prévision de croissance est un
peu ambitieuse je trouve pour ma part
que nos efforts vers le plein emploi
sont la marque de l'ambition forte que
nous portons qui est inédite depuis
longtemps dans notre pays je relève
s'agissant de la croissance que votre
avis indique qu'une accélération de
l'activité en cours d'année vous ne
l'avez dit ne peut pas être exclu car
des signaux positifs existent l'économie
fait preuve d'une résilience l'emploi
demeure dynamique le risque d'une
rupture des approvisionnements en
électricité ou en gaz par est désormais
limité et les tensions sur les prix de
l'énergie s'atténue il me paraît
nécessaire à ce stade de souligner que
quel que soit la réalité de la situation
économique des années à venir qui ne
peut jamais être prédit de manière
certaine la nécessité de la réforme est
évidente dans l'ensemble des scénariés
qui sont envisagés en 2027 ça a été
rappelé le déficit du système de
retraite atteint de Ré 0,4% du PIB quel
que soit le scénario retenu ce déficit
serait compris entre 0,3 et 0,7 point de
PIB enfin concernant à proprement parler
l'incidence budgétaire du projet de loi
la vidéo commissariat du Haut Conseil
pardon souligne que la réforme
présenterait en 2023 un coup net de 0,4
milliards d'euros vous jugez réaliste
cette estimation ce coup et donc bien la
preuve de l'importance des mesures
compensatoires qui accompagnent le
relèvement de l'âge d'ouverture des
droits et l'allongement de la durée des
cotisations permettant de liquider sa
retraite à taux plein ces mesures
d'accompagnement sont centrales et
permettent de faire de la réforme qui
vous est proposée une réforme de
responsabilité mais également de justice
alors chers collègues quel serait un
système de retraite non financé ce
serait un système dans lequel les
pensions ne peuvent pas être servies ou
alors peuvent l'être mais à un niveau
réduit nier le besoin de réduction du
déficit de du système de retraite c'est
donc quelque part accepter une baisse
des droits des assurés ce à quoi le
gouvernement et la majorité ne peuvent
se résoudre mais qui semble convenir en
revanche à certains d'entre nous pour
terminer j'aurais souhaité vous demander
quelques précisions au plan de
l'équilibre le Haut conseil c'est bien
entendu concentré sur 2023 mais quelle
analyse pourrait-il faire de la
trajectoire pour les régimes
obligatoires de base et le Fonds de
solidarité pour la vieillesse ainsi que
pour la branche vieillesse d'ici 2026 au
plan des recettes votre avis estime que
la prévision de la masse salariale pour
23 est un peu basse c'est une
observation que vous aviez déjà faite
par le passé cette elle vérifiée
pouvez-vous expliquer les raisons
suscitant cette remarque et quelle
projection alternative retenez-vous par
rapport à la cible de 5% que se donne le
gouvernement quel serait l'effet sur le
produit des cotisations et contributions
de sécurité sociale
au plan des dépenses vous soulignez que
les effets de la hausse du minimum
contributif reste incertain à ce stade
d'où proviennent ces difficultés
notamment concernant le coût de la
revalorisation des pensions déjà
liquidés et je me félicite d'ailleurs de
cette intégration fruit du dialogue
entre l'exécutif et les groupes
parlementaires enfin concernant
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
permettant de liquider sa retraite à
taux plein disposez-vous de données sur
les premiers effets observés sur le sol
de public de l'entrée en application de
la réforme Touraine en 2020 je vous
remercie merci jean-renic aznove merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup pour votre
exposé
extrêmement clair peut-être avant de
vous poser trois questions un point sur
l'intervention du président concret je
comprends peut-être que j'ai mal compris
mais que le Conseil des finances
publiques était saisi pour avis sur
l'impact en 2023 et donc je crois qu'on
ne peut pas spéculer sur ce qu'on a été
cet avis sur 2024 ou d'autres non le
document dit que on ne sait pas et ça
non on ne sait pas mais la saisine est
bien portée sur sur 2023 première
remarche je
sur les prévisions écoutez je pense que
partage le point de vue on avait déjà eu
cette cette discussion c'est vrai que
les prévisions sont volontariste mais
comme vous l'avez souligné les chiffres
du chômage en particulier qui sont
tombés aujourd'hui ou hier
souligne voilà que mon quart de toujours
comme objectif le retour en plein emploi
d'une part et donc une croissance
soutenue l'année prochaine en tous les
cas supérieur à ce que disent encore un
certain nombre de prévisionnistes sur la
loi de
programmation des finances publiques
vous soulignez je ne peux être que
d'accord le handicap constitue pour la
France la loi l'absence d'une loi de
programmation donc en vigueur pour le
pilotage pluriel indispensable à la
bonne gestion publique et pour la
crédibilité de notre gouvernance
budgétaire et financière
dire que redire au groupe et au députés
qui sont ici que
nous n'avons pas voté en première
lecture mais que j'espère que nous
aurons l'occasion cette année
d'examiner en secondaire je me suis donc
à la disposition de l'ensemble des
groupes pour travailler sur cette
deuxième lecture de la loi de
programmation
peut-être monsieur le Président votre
avis stipulé dans la loi de
programmation votre travail sur la
programmation que
ça manquait un peu de d'éléments sur ce
qui sous-tendait cette trajectoire en
particulier sur les réformes qui étaient
engagées est-ce que la réforme des
retraites telle qu'elle apparaît
aujourd'hui vous rassure un peu sur la
crédibilité de cette trajectoire
troisième élément
d'expliquer de manière très claire si
certains n'avaient pas compris dans tous
les cas pour moi c'est extrêmement clair
l'impact des 2023 est positif et apporte
des mesures de justice qui vont coûter
400 millions d'euros qui soulignent là
la hausse des pensions minimales pour de
très nombreux très nombreux Français il
faut le dire
ma question sur la trajectoire c'est que
les coûts sont à peu près certain tous
les cas parce que ces mesures sociales
d'accompagnement en revanche les
hypothèses de cotisation supplémentaire
sont basées sur à la fois un taux de
productivité de 1% sur l'ensemble de la
période et un taux de chômage de 4,5%
aussi donc vous avez pas eu tous les
éléments mais est-ce que ces deux
hypothèses vous paraissent aujourd'hui
crédible ou optimiste
enfin sur le l'impact de la baisse du
coût de l'énergie un effet positif et un
effet négatif avec la rentrée marginale
et évidemment le coût du bouclier des
différentes mesures est-ce que le solde
de votre point de vue est positif pour
les finances publiques en 2023 si le
coût de l'énergie continuait à baisser
comme c'est la tendance actuelle merci
beaucoup merci
Pierre Bousquet ici
comme je le disais je vais être décevant
surtout ce qui concerne la trajectoire
je vais pas commencer à la prendre par
petit bout par ici par là parce que en
réalité nous n'avons pas suffisamment
d'informations
des finances publiques ou demande à
saisi le HP et que sur les conséquences
de la réforme des retraites sur la seule
année 2023 il y a une annexe qui sont
les hémoratifs à l'article liminaire
portant sur l'année 2023 en réponse à
des demandes répétées le HCP a fini par
obtenir en complément une annexe ou plfs
pourtant sujet 2023 2026 qui a permis
d'établir une comparaison avec les
chiffres de la FS en cours et donc une
comparaison avec la loi de programmation
de finance publique mais seulement
partiel parce que en termes de champ
c'est plus restreint c'est les régimes
de base et le SSB non pas toutes
administrations publiques et d'horizon
puisque c'est 2026 c'est pas 2027 pour
aller plus loin et pour pouvoir se
prononcer sur le réalisme des recettes
et des pensées de la 2023 il eût fallu
que que nous puissions disposer des
résultats chiffrés présentés dans le
rapport sur les objectifs et les effets
du projet de réforme des retraites mais
aussi de détails sur les hypothèses et
sur les mécanismes conduisant ces
chiffrages qui ne figure pas dans ce
rapport donc c'est à partir de cette
gynés 3 informations lacunaire même si
il y a eu un progrès dans l'échange avec
les administrations que je veux
reconnaître mais encore insuffisant que
je peux répondre à vos questions ce qui
me permet de sauter tout de suite la
question de rapporteur général je vais
revenir aux autres sur est-ce que nous
sommes rassurés par assuré
des informations nous avons nous ne
pouvons raisonner qu'en différentiel et
ce que je peux dire en effet c'est que
la réforme des retraites premièrement ne
suffit pas elle seule à justifier la
trajectoire de finance publique mais
qu'elle les tailles en partie mais que
par rapport à ce que contenait le loi la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques il manque encore 0,7 milliards
d'euros en 2026 sur les régimes de base
et du SSV d'ailleurs je veux corriger
tout de suite de illusions d'optique la
première sur les 0,4 pour 2023 ça coûte
mais ça devrait rapporter plus après
donc ce que ça démonte simplement c'est
qu'il y a des mesures qui jouent tout de
suite leur effet alors que les économies
et les recettes viennent plus tard
deuxième illusion d'optique dans l'autre
sens pas parce que nous disons je
constate que l'impact sur la dette ne se
voit pas
mais ça veut pas dire qu'il y a pas
d'impact du tout d'une réforme sur la
dette c'est simplement que comme il y
avait déjà une réforme pas spécifiée du
tout celle-ci n'est pas spécifiée
suffisamment dans le la loi de
programmation de finance publique
on voit que ça rapporte un petit peu
moins que ce qui était prévu au départ
ce pas dire que ça rapporte rien si je
me fais comprendre où à peu près
sur
la question du président de la
commission des finances qui évidemment
très importante ce mur d'investissement
charge de la dette investissement bon
ça aurait peut-être surpris dans la
bouche du président de la Cour des
comptes qui est aussi président du HFP
mais j'ai bien parlé d'un mur
d'evincissement et l'investissement à
financé je suis pas du tout en train de
dire qu'il faut stopper la dépense
publique non sur toute une série de
secteurs nous avons besoin
d'investissement là où je peux être me
distinguer de vous monsieur le Président
vous me le pardonnerez c'est que je
pense qu'un investissement doit être
financé et que donc en face de
l'investissement il faut bien avoir des
recettes ou des marges de manoeuvre bon
et tous ce point de vue là je le redis
la course à l'endettement n'est en aucun
cas la solution parce que un nous avons
déjà une dérive de notre endettement de
55 points c'est pour ça que de ce
chiffre de cette dérive elle est aussi
relative par rapport à nos partenaires 3
et comme observer par les institutions
internationales par l'Union européenne
et accessoirement par les marchés
financiers il faut bien quand même
camerounais cette dette se finance ne le
perdons pas de vue et puis j'ajoute 4
que nous sommes quand même dans un
moment
et je les dénoncé
ou cet écart qui existe déjà entre nos
finances publiques et celle de
partenaire est en train de se creuser
c'est pour ça que j'avais évoqué l'idée
que nous étions sur une trajectoire trop
ambitieuse les autres viennent en
dessous 2025 nous nous sommes sur 1027
avec une dette qui reste plate donc
je nuance votre propos pas ma propre
approche qui est que oui il y a des
investissements bien sûr mais ce n'est
pas un surcroît d'être qu'on doit les
financer c'est pas une diminution de la
dette qui permet de retrouver des marges
manoeuvre alors après il y a d'autres
solutions vous avez évoqué les dépenses
fiscales et sociales la Cour des comptes
ne cesse de répéter que qu'en effet il
faut quand même s'y attaquer
sérieusement parce qu'il y en a quand
même des ressources à utiliser puis il y
a d'autres procédés qui seraient par
exemple la hausse des impôts que nous ne
recommandons pas mais voilà
l'autre solution magique la croissance
n'y réponds pas non plus j'appelle un
renforcement de la croissance
potentielle du pays et l'investissement
entraîne cela mais n'imaginons pas que
nous entrons dans les trentes glorieuses
en tout hypothèse dans les années qui
viennent nous aurons une croissance
disons limité ou modérés madame la
députée
vous avez peut-être entendu dire ça ce
matin mais je crois pas vous l'avoir dit
parce que je ne me mettrai jamais de
dire des parlementaires qu'ils sont
irresponsables
en tout cas maintenant que je ne suis
plus des vôtres et que je n'appartiens
pas à un gouvernement donc comme
président de la Cour des comptes comme
président du hcfp non
je dis en revanche que l'absence de LPFP
n'est pas une anecdote et que ce serait
quelque chose qui pourrait à terme
entraîner des conséquences sérieuses
voire grave donc j'utilise mes propres
mots mais je le dis ainsi et c'est sur
enfin les mesures salariales c'est
la masse salariale c'est pas la première
fois que la Cour annonce que la
prévision de ma salariale est basse nous
l'avions déjà fait l'automne 2021 et de
fait le masse salariale était plus
dynamique que prévu ce n'est pas une
preuve que nous disons toujours le vrai
simplement ce qui nous fait dire cette
fois-ci que les bases c'est que c'est
lié à ce que nous disons sur l'inflation
comme nous pensons que la prévision
d'inflation est trop faible salut
gouvernement est à 4,2 la nôtre est pas
le consensus 4,8 et que sans avoir une
boucle pris salaire nous avons quand
même un certain nombre de mécanismes qui
sont les mécanisations comme le SMIC et
puis tout de même des phénomènes dont
les entreprises tiennent compte si
l'inflation était effectivement plus
élevée et nous pensons qu'elle le sera
que les 4,2 ou qu'elle risque de l'être
à ce moment-là le masse salariale
devrait être également être plus élevé
voilà ce que nous estimons
par ailleurs sur les questions du
bouclier fiscal
une baisse des prix pour être en effet
favorable mais les mécanismes sont
complexes le gars est probable mais
incertain dans son ampleur ce qui fait
que
notre jugement sur les finances
publiques pour
2023 nous l'avons nuancé c'est-à-dire
très clairement avec ce que nous
connaissions à l'automne nous pensions
que le déficit serait supérieur à 5% là
maintenant je ne suis pas capable de
vous dire s'il sera supérieur égal ou
inférieur l'ampleur des mécanismes en
jeu dans un sens ou dans l'autre reste
quand même trop incertain mais nous
avons tenu à marquer que il y avait tout
de même des effets qui maintenant
jouaient dans l'autre sens
dans les années que j'ai passé à
Bruxelles j'ai appris un néologisme
charmant qui est qui est à Bruxelles on
pense qu'il y a des risques à la hausse
des risques à la baisse en français en
général les risques sont plutôt à la
baisse mais il existe aussi des risques
à la hausse en l'occurrence voilà ce que
je voulais souligner
merci on va passer aux orateurs de cours
de groupe Mathieu Lefebvre pour le
groupe Renaissance oui merci monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le Président
Moscovici à mon tour de déplorer
l'absence préjudiciable de loi de
programmation qui nous empêche au fond
de jouer notre rôle de contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement on ne peut pas
juger de la cohérence de l'article
liminaire avec les orientations plus
réelles de soldes malgré tout force est
constater que le gouvernement a été
transparent dès le début puisque tous
les textes financiers prévoyaient une
réforme des retraites l'objectif
d'augmentation des dépenses publiques de
0,6% au volume était évidemment
incompatible avec une augmentation des
dépenses de retraite de 1,8% volume
première question est-ce que ces
hypothèses permettent de renforcer la
sincérité des prévisions qui sont ici
présentées ensuite on a beau chercher
dans tous les sens et retourner le
problème dans tous les sens on a un
problème on a une impasse de financement
pour équilibrer notre système de
retraite à
très court terme c'est à dire à horizon
2030 sauf en effet à faire le choix de
l'endettement et donc de
l'enrichissement de nos créanciers qui
sont je le rappelle aux deux tiers des
étrangers de ce point de vue vous
indiquez que la réforme des retraites
est indispensable à la réduction de
notre niveau d'endettement mais qu'elle
ne suffira pas
à abaisser ce niveau d'endettement et à
faire face aux chocs macroéconomique
futur comme au besoin d'investissement
dans la transition écologique j'ai donc
deux questions quel serait dans le fond
le coût de l'inaction c'est à dire le
statut quo à horizon 2030 il y a
fortiori quel serait le coût pour nos
finances publiques d'un abaissement de
l'âge légal de la du départ en retraite
à 60 ans
enfin monsieur le Président vous avez
dit le sujet c'est un sujet état mais il
a toujours été dit que dans cette
réforme il y avait pas un euro de
cotisations vieillesse qui n'irait à
autre chose car équilibrer le système le
système de retraite par répartition et
dans le fond le sujet c'est en effet un
sujet de finance publique mais pas que
quand les dépenses de retraite elle
représente un quart du PIB il était
évident que c'est l'ensemble de nos
finances publiques qui sont impactées
par la réforme des retraites dernière
question quelle est selon vous l'impact
sur la croissance potentielle du PIB de
cette réforme est-ce qu'on peut
considérer que cette réforme a un impact
positif sur la croissance du PIB je vous
remercie merci Frédéric cabrolier pour
l'assemblée
bien alors déjà vous avez indiqué que le
scénario macronomique qui est
macroéconomique est retenu par le
gouvernement est optimiste
prévision de ma salariale un peu basse
prévision d'inflation un peu faible et
provision de croissance élevée ensuite
on a on a reçu je vais revenir sur
l'audition qu'on a faite de manière
commune avec la commission des affaires
sociales de Monsieur bras qui
effectivement nous a dit que c'était pas
une réforme du système de retraite mais
que c'était ça concernait la politique
globale des finances publiques alors il
nous a rappelé ça vient d'être appelé
que les dépenses de retraite
représentaient un quart 25% des dépenses
publiques et si on n'avait pas fait
cette réforme des retraites les dépenses
de retraite ça vient d'être appelé
également à aller augmenter de 1,8% par
an alors que pour passer sous les trois
pour cent à l'horizon 2027 de déficit
public du PIB et bien il fallait que les
dépenses des finances publiques
n'augmentent pas de plus de 0,6% par an
et vous donc on voit bien que c'est un
problème de dette et vous vous le
confirmez en disant que le cet objectif
de dette en disant que la réforme des
retraites présentées dans ce PLF ne
suffit pas à elle seule à atteindre
l'objectif de retour à des niveaux de
dettes de dette qui permettent à la
France de disposer de marge de manœuvre
suffisante
quand un lac de la réforme ça a été
signalé
le Haut conseil dont vous indiquez que
vous évaluez l'impact de la réforme des
retraites en 2023 à 400 millions d'euros
et que vous pouvez pas vous projeter sur
les années suivantes
faute du vote vous dites de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
donc si vous voulez la question qu'on
peut se poser c'est en définitive quelle
est l'intérêt de cette réforme des
retraites si comme vous le dites la
réforme des retraites ne devrait pas
améliorer la trajectoire de la dette et
alors que c'est l'objectif et deuxième
question vous signalez je l'ai dit dans
la réforme des retraites présentées ne
suffit pas à elle seule qu'est-ce que
vous proposez donc pour réduire donc la
dette pour réduire les dépenses
publiques qu'est-ce que vous proposez
d'autres quand vous qu'est-ce que vous
entendez par a elle seule merci David
Giraud pour France insoumise
merci monsieur le Président
dans son projet de loi de finance 2023
le gouvernement avait annoncé la couleur
il disait je cite que les
administrations de sécurité sociale
participeront à la maîtrise de
l'évolution des dépenses permise
notamment par la réforme des retraites
fin de la citation voilà donc le but
réel de la réforme des retraites faire
des économies et de quoi s'aperçoit-on
aujourd'hui
d'abord que la réforme va avoir un
impact très faible sur nos finances
publiques on se demande donc pourquoi on
fait subir ça aux Français mais qu'en
plus au-delà de 2023 on a aucune idée de
l'impact de cette réforme sur nos
finances nous avançons donc en d'autres
termes les yeux bandés volontairement
qui plus est parce que vous nous avez
alerté monsieur le président du Haut
conseil sur le fait que les scénarios
présentés par le gouvernement
sont tout du moins un peu trop optimiste
j'ai plusieurs questions
j'ai noté que vous nous annoncez dès
l'année prochaine que 50000 personnes
verront leur départ à la retraite
retardé est-ce que vous nous confirmez
cette information qui va prendre ce
recul et combien de temps combien de
mois
par ailleurs avez-vous prévu monsieur le
Président le coup social de cette
réforme parce que le FCE parle de 277000
chômeurs supplémentaires à horizons 10
ans pour un coup de 2,8 milliards
d'euros quand l'adresse elle estime à
3,5 milliards d'euros la conséquence
d'un report de l'âge de départ à la
retraite ce que en d'autres termes on ne
payera pas en retraite on le payera en
minima sociaux et en charge avez-vous
une estimation de ses coûts enfin le
gouvernement nous dit que le déficit du
système de retraite sera de 0,7% du PIB
en 2050 c'est oublier que le PIB
d'aujourd'hui ne sera pas le PIB de
demain qui a priori sera bien plus élevé
en 2050 qu'en 2030 avez-vous donc des
estimations qui permettent de mesurer
l'évolution du PIB français pour voir ce
que représente réellement en 2050 ce
léger déficit du système de retraite sur
notre produit antérieur brut enfin sur
la loi de programmation des finances
publiques vous êtes évidemment dans
votre rôle
je rappelle que l'Assemblée nationale a
refusé en majorité cette loi parce
qu'elle l'avait des prévisions de
croissance et d'inflation qui n'étaient
pas sérieuses et qu'elle promettait des
choses comme l'austérité dans nos
communes qui n'étaient pas acceptable
politiquement raison pour laquelle nous
redemandons à la minorité présidentielle
de revenir à la raison sur ce sujet
merci Véronique louvagi pour les
républicains merci beaucoup monsieur le
président
mais bien voulu nous donner j'ai noté
que vous ne pouviez pas répondre à un
certain nombre de questions donc je ne
vous en poserai pas je ferai état de
remarques et de regrets qui peut-être
susciteront des réactions
une première remarque vous savez indiqué
effectivement nous le retrouvons qu'il
n'y a pas de modification finalement
dans ce PLFSS sur la situation
macroéconomique par rapport à septembre
2022 à la fois au niveau de la
croissance que certes vous jugez élevé
l'inflation qui ont jugez un peu faible
et l'estimation basse un peu de la masse
salariale j'ai un regret que
effectivement le gouvernement n'est pas
ajusté ces hypothèses et que finalement
ce soit ici un copier-coller je
m'interroge toutefois sur la situation
et l'impact des taux d'intérêt qui
continuent à augmenter depuis septembre
dernier une réaction également sur la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques je note votre regret j'ai le
même regret nous avons le même regret
et derrière j'ai eu un autre regret que
le gouvernement n'est pas entendu en
tout cas nos messages et finalement les
messages que au niveau du groupe les
républicains nous avions adressé ils
sont confortés par vos remarques dans
votre avis déjà dans la vie du mois de
septembre quand vous soulignez
l'importance de la maîtrise de la
dépense publique couplée à la recherche
d'une plus grande efficacité et en
janvier dans cette avis où vous indiquez
que la réforme des retraites ne suffit
pas à elle seule à atteindre un objectif
de financement des besoins
d'investissement public liés notamment
aux enjeux climatiques ce qui me fait
dire que nous avons eu raison de ne pas
voter en faveur de programmation des
finances publiques telles qu'elle était
présentée je voudrais également noter
l'impact sur les comptes 2023 et la
brutalité l'impact de la réforme des
retraites puisqu'effectivement 50 000
personnes qui sont nées après le 1er
septembre
1961 et avant le 30 31 décembre 1961 qui
pouvait partir à la retraite au 1er
octobre de cette année au 1er octobre
2023 ne pourront pour un certain nombre
naturelle ne partir qu'au 1er janvier
2024 quand on sait que une réforme de
retraite c'est un projet de vie qui se
prépare longtemps à l'avance c'est un
regret et je terminerai également que je
regrette que vous n'ayez pas de données
sur l'impact sur les années futures ça
n'est pas logique que le gouvernement ne
vous est pas alimenté sur un certain
nombre d'éléments merci qui pour le
groupe socialiste monsieur Brun
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Président maître une remarque
illuminée à sur la question de votre
programmation relative finance publique
vous êtes effectivement dans votre rôle
sur ce sujet et je m'interroge néanmoins
à nouveau sur l'utilité de ses lois vous
nous dites effectivement que c'est
important que nous adoptions une puis je
note que dans l'avant dernier rapport du
Haut Conseil vous écriviez non
contraignante reposant sur des
hypothèses généralement optimistes et
rapidement obsolète nos objectifs donc
rarement été atteints dans ces
conditions on peut se demander quel est
finalement l'urgence d'adopter un
document bavard que personne ne
respectera j'ajoute par ailleurs que les
sanctions qui sont prévues aujourd'hui
par les traités l'article 8 du TSCG
n'ont jamais été déployés ça n'a jamais
été le cas et qu'enfin qu'est-ce qui
empêche le Haut conseil de regarder le
décalage entre les budgets que nous
votons et finalement la norme qui
ressort du programme de stabilité qui
est un document
identiques sinon comparable à une loi de
programmation des finances publiques
j'ai quelques questions sur le rapport
que vous venez de nous présenter
pardonnez-moi d'abord vous nous dites
que il y a un caractère incomplet des
informations qui nous ont été transmises
par le gouvernement pouvez-vous nous
dire quelles informations manquent et
auraient été
utile au Conseil ensuite vous nous dites
que les prévisions de croissance du
gouvernement sont élevés au-dessus du
consensus des économistes vous dites
manque de prise en considération du
niveau élevé de l'inflation mais aussi
durcissement des politiques monétaires
quels autres facteurs de freinage et aux
conseils anticipent-ils que gouvernement
ne prend pas en considération puis enfin
dernière question le Conseil relève que
la réforme des retraites aura un impact
très faible ce finance publique en 2023
et qu'un coup net estimé à 0,4 milliards
d'euros mais note que les incertitudes
entourent le coût de la hausse minimum
en contributif quels sont ces
incertitudes et surtout qu'elle pourrait
être l'ampleur des variations
éventuelles pour 2023
merci de Félicie Girard
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président vous voilà
de même après avoir été auditionné par
notre commission sur le PLF et le plfs
2023 pour venir à nous éclairer pour
venir éclairer à nouveau nos débat et
informer les Français sur la pérennité
de nos finances
notre système de retraite connaît depuis
de nombreuses années des débats sur sa
soutenabilité selon les prévisions du
corps et cela dans n'importe quel
scénario même le plus optimiste notre
système de retraite va vers un déficit
chronique de financement à long terme le
gouvernement a donc annoncé une réforme
pour pallier en amont les déficits et
pour garantir un système de retraite
juste et autonome pour les futurs
générations par cette mesure d'âge légal
de départ en retraite l'objectif est
d'empêcher la fragilisation de notre
système par répartition la question de
l'équilibre de nos comptes publics est
en effet majeur surtout lorsqu'il s'agit
de notre modèle de solidarité qui je le
crois nous est à tous très chers vous
avez monsieur le Président la charge de
surveiller les dépenses de l'État et la
bonne administration de nos comptes
publics bien que vous n'ayez pas été en
mesure d'analyser en profondeur les
implications à long terme de cette
réforme comme vous l'avez précisé
pourriez-vous au regard des éléments
dont vous disposez nous indiquez si
l'équilibre des comptes actuels serait
soutenable à long terme sans réforme et
êtes-vous et êtes-vous en mesure à la
lumière de des modèles économiques
traditionnels de nous dire si cette
réforme telle qu'elle nous est présentée
aura un impact positif ou négatif sur
l'équilibre de nos finances publiques je
vous remercie
pour le groupe écologique
merci monsieur le président
de rappeler que la réforme des retraites
prévues dans ces PLFSS est injuste et
injustifié je dois dire que la lecture
de votre avis ne modifie pas notre
appréciation en particulier nous notons
que la hausse de l'âge légal de départ
dès septembre pourrait conduire 50 000
personnes à décaler leur départ ainsi
cela toucherait directement parmi les
features retraités de 2023 environ une
personne sur 15 dans votre avis vous
notez également que le caractère
incomplet des informations qui ont été
transmises par le gouvernement empêche
d'évaluer l'incidence de moyen terme de
la réforme des retraites sur les
finances publiques et ceci nous paraît
extrêmement dommage dommageable car de
ce fait ni le débat parlementaire ni
l'opinion publique ne peuvent être
éclairés sur l'opportunité ou la
nécessité de cette réforme d'où mes deux
questions la première pensez-vous qu'il
est acceptable que la représentation
parlementaire et au-delà les Français
souffrent d'un déficit d'information sur
une réforme d'une telle envergure
comment pouvons-nous nous prononcer sur
un texte poser des informations
nécessaires à l'éclairage de notre
décision et ma deuxième question vous
insistez sur la nécessité de réduire la
dette publique pensez-vous dès lors
qu'il était important de réduire les
impôts de production de 14 milliards
d'euros entre 2020 et 2023 ne
pensez-vous pas qu'il aurait été bien
plus adéquat de maintenir la
contribution des entreprises aux
dépenses publiques plutôt que d'aller
chercher des économies par un report de
l'âge légal dans les Français ne veulent
pas
merci et pour terminer Charles de
Courson pour le groupe
monsieur le Premier Président quatre
petites questions
vous nous indiquez pour la deuxième fois
que les prévisions de croissance du PIB
en 2023 vous paraissent
trop élevés vous dites reste élevé
qu'est-ce qui se passerait si on
dégringolait de 1% à 0,2,03 % c'est à
dire à peu près les consensus actuel
même si on a qui sont même en croissance
négative est-ce qu'on ne perdrait pas
huit dix milliards de recettes fiscales
première question
deuxième question sur la masse salariale
là vous dites au contraire qu'elle vous
paraît un peu basse à 5% mais 5% avec
une inflation de 4-3 c'est encore une
augmentation de pouvoir d'achat à la
masse salariale de 0,7 si on retire
l'augmentation des effectifs à 0,2 03 on
est encore à 0,405 or d'après ce qu'on
voit dans les négociations salariales
pour 2023 dans beaucoup d'entreprises on
est des réévaluations inférieures
à une croissance des prix tel qu'elle
est envisagée à 4,3% hors tabac
troisième alors donc est-ce que vous
pouvez un peu nous préciser cela
troisième question
vous nous signalez qu'on a une très
légère baisse de la dette publique mais
avec beaucoup de subtilité vous ne dites
que c'est grâce essentiellement une
mobilisation de la trésorerie
excédentaire de l'État accumulé afin
2022 est-ce que vous pourriez nous dire
à hauteur de combien
on a eu on s'est surendetter si je peux
dire afin 2022 par rapport aux besoins
pour donner l'illusion que la dette
publique fléchissait légèrement en
pourcentage du PIB et puis dernière
question
dans vos compétences vous devez donner
une appréciation sur le réalisme des
prévisions de dépenses
mais l'article liminaire concerne par
que la sécurité sociale concerne l'état
et les collectivités locales est-ce que
vous pourriez nous dire un petit mot sur
est-ce que vous avez eu le temps de
regarder le dérapage du coude des
intérêts de la dette puisqu'on nous
avait expliqué que l'intérêt de la dette
à 10 ans on serait à deux deux en début
d'année 2023 et à deux trois en fin
d'année alors qu'on a déjà largement
dépassé c'est tôt
merci juste une petite question est-ce
que tu as par Fabien Philippot il y aura
d'autres personnes qui veulent
s'inscrire après
oui mais si non mais il y en a d'autres
donc je les prends après pierre
mouscovici réponse
extrêmement générale en revenant sur
d'ailleurs une question du président
laquelle j'avais pas répondu
si je vais raisonner encore une fois sur
une réforme des retraites
nous estimons en effet comme d'autres
institutions
qu'il y a un besoin de financement à
combler qui peut-être comblé par le
répondeur retraite qui peut encore une
fois peut prendre plusieurs voix c'est
pas à moi de choisir c'est le Parlement
c'est le gouvernement ce sont les
partenaires sociaux mais il doit être
clair qu'il ne s'agit pas là de payer le
déficit de l'État
une retraite c'est pas un couteau suisse
c'est une réforme qui est faite pour
équilibrer le système de retraite et pas
pour faire autre chose une fois que l'on
a dit ça on arrive sur toute une série
de questions que vous avez posé mesdames
et messieurs les députés d'abord sur le
coût d'une action je redis qu'il
n'appartient pas au Conseil des finances
publiques ici de se prononcer sur des
choix politiques
nous avons là je parle de la Cour des
comptes produit note d'études
structurelles sur le système des
retraites qui concluait la nécessité
d'une réforme encore une fois c'est pas
à nous de dire quels sont les voies et
moyens pourquoi parce qu'il y a des
déficits de prévisionnels cours des
années à venir et nous indiquions que
les marges manœuvres pour de nouvelles
de taux de cotisation à pas assez
restreinte dès lors que la France a déjà
le tout prélèvement obligatoire le plus
élevé de l'Union européenne donc nous
pensions qu'il fallait maîtriser les
dépendeurs retraite et que encore une
fois c'était tout de même la durée
l'âge qui comptait même si ça ne
prononcions pas sur l'âge légal sur le
moment de le faire sur la façon de le
faire etc et donc il y a un problème de
soutenabilité
est-ce que la réforme des retraites
assure l'équipe du régime par
répartition à moyen et long terme
là je le dis par rapport aux mesures qui
sont exposées et non pas par rapport aux
informations dont nous disposions parce
que un député m'a demandé si nous
n'avions aucune idée sur ce que ça
rapportait nous n'avons pas d'idées
suffisante pour pouvoir en quelque sorte
que le certifier puisque notre
information est lacunaire mais pour le
reste il y a des informations qui ont
été rendues publiques par le
gouvernement au moment de la
présentation de la réforme qui laisse à
penser que les dispositions du peller
FSS conduirait à réduire le déficit de
13 milliards en 2030 chiffrage qui
compte produirait qui correspond à
l'ordre de grandeur du déficit du régime
simuler par le corps mais comme
l'indiqué le conseil dans son avis les
informations ne vont pas permis
d'évaluer l'incidence de moyen terme de
la réforme des retraites sur le moyen
sur les finances publiques donc encore
une fois il y a un impact ce que nous ne
pouvons pas faire nous c'est en quelque
sorte
sur une autre question qui est de savoir
si la réforme des retraites contribue à
abaisser la dette
là encore il faut bien prendre les
notions relatives
et là il y a une illusion d'optique qui
ne doit pas nourrir le débat public de
manière
erronée nous ne disons pas que ça n'a
pas d'impact sur la tête ça n'a pas que
sur la dette ce que nous disons c'est
que ça n'a pas plutôt inférieur sur la
dette à ce qui avait été prévu sans
spécifier ce qui était la réforme dans
les documents dont nous disposions
antérieurement et donc disons que en
tout hypothèse ça devrait laisser la
dette sur une trajectoire assez plate
jusqu'au 2027 ça ne modifie pas
en revanche s'il n'y avait pas une
réforme des retraites alors à ce
moment-là la dette aurait augmenté de
manière significative d'ici à 2027 sur
la question qui m'a été également posée
de la croissance potentielle
la réforme des retraites une réforme des
retraites doit avoir un impact favorable
sur la croissance potentielle parce que
ça un impact sur un facteur de
production qui est le travail
il y a plus de quantité de travail il y
a plus de quantité de travail il devrait
y avoir plus de croissance potentielles
cela dit ça après vous tombez sur des
choix politiques qui est de savoir si on
consacre davantage de temps dans la vie
ou travail ou loisirs la vie ça c'est
soit sur lequel nous ne pouvons pas nous
prononcer sur les 50 000 personnes qui
décalent leur départ à la retraite en
2023 là c'est un chiffre qui est dans
les documents nous avons été saisis il
s'agit du nombre de personnes qui sont
réforme des retraites serait parti dès
lors 62 ans à partir des premiers
octobre novembre ou décembre sont la
réforme qui devront donc décaler leur
départ et environ 200000 personnes par
an qui partent en retraite dès l'âge
légal atteints
sur un peu plus de 700 000 par an les
personnes qui comptaient à partir à la
retraite dès leur 62 ans à partir des
1er octobre novembre ou décembre ne vont
reporter leur départ représente un quart
des personnes qui auraient pris leur
retraite des 62 ans il y a donc environ
50 000 personnes qui devront décaler
leur départ en retraite en 2022 et ça
c'est pour un trimestre qui veut dire
que ce sera effectivement de l'ordre de
200000 pour la suite assez clairement
les différents chiffres qui ont servi à
ce calcul sont me semble-t-il tout à
fait étayés puisqu'il provient du
panorama sur les retraites et les
retraités de la dresse sur la question
qui m'a été posée sur
l'évaluation 07 point de PIB en 2050
c'est par définition pas du Pipe
d'aujourd'hui si c'était du pub
d'aujourd'hui ce serait pour parler de
manière un peu nette davantage
où on est la charge de la dette contenu
de la hausse des taux d'intérêt là où
c'est taux d'intérêt surtout celle de
l'inflation conduit une augmentation de
la charge de la dette en 2022 cette
dernière devrait avoir augmenté d'un peu
plus de 12 milliards en 2022 pour
l'ensemble des administrations publiques
passant de 35 à 47 en comptabilité
nationale en 2023 louant prévoit une un
reflux la charge de la dette de 3
milliards à 44 milliards qui provient du
repli de la charge des titres indexés en
lien avec la baisse attendue de
l'inflation mais nous ne savons pas non
plus qu'elle sera l'effet de la haute
étau et contenu de cela et quand tu de
l'inflation qui pourrait être plus
élevée que prévu ce recul de la charge
de la dette n'est pas acquis donc je
peux pas dire ce sera 44 ou 47 mais nous
restons sur des niveaux qui sont
beaucoup plus élevés même deux fois plus
élevés qu'il y a quelques années combien
coûte la hausse du minimum contributif
son coût est prévu à 0,4 milliards
d'euros en 2023 par le gouvernement il
sera partiellement financé par une
solidarité interbranche les contours
exacts de la mesure et c'est éventuel
financement reste à préciser sur la
croissance et les impacts sur le déficit
monsieur le député
le seul croissance du gouvernement est à
un point il est au-dessus du haut de la
fourchette puisque je le redis le
consensus des économistes est à 0,2 ce
qui s'est en effet comme vous voyez
monsieur le Président entre certains qui
prévoit encore une récession et d'autres
que le FMI les plus optimiste étant à
0,7
nous aurions pu être plus sévère dans le
ton nous l'avons pas été
et tout à fait volontairement parce que
en effet
c'est vrai que l'environnement
international demeure mal orienté en
mais il y a eu des réseaux de
modification en Chine de la politique
par rapport au covid le durcissement des
politiques monétaires est encore à
évaluer et l'ensemble
de ceux qui apprécient le climat et les
indicateurs avancés vous l'avez dit
monsieur le rapporteur général font que
on ne peut pas totalement exclure une
bonne surprise en tout cas nous ne
sommes pas capables de dire quelle est
l'ampleur de la dégradation nous
continuons de penser que c'est moins de
1 point mais alors qu'il y a si j'étais
venu devant vous il y a un mois j'aurais
pensé qu'on était très près de la
récession nous nous pensons plus il
n'est pas exclu totalement voilà
pourquoi nous sommes restés sur une
tonalité assez modérée samedi je pense
qu'à un moment donné il faudrait que le
gouvernement ajuste sa prévision de
croissance quand les informations seront
un peu plus solides et pas seulement sur
un trimestre
ne serait-ce que pour pouvoir
effectivement faire des calculs sur le
déficit et pour la sincérité non pas la
sincérité pour la bonne tenue du débat
public parce que je n'aime pas le mot de
sincérité je pense que avant d'accuser
un déficit un budget des temps sincère
il faut quand même aller loin il faut
vraiment avoir une intention de tromper
je suis en général très
loyal mon prédécesseur
qui a fait un excellent travail mais
quand était sorti l'idée qu'un budget
était insincert c'était dans 2017 ça
m'avait pas en vérité en balais comme
notion je l'avais dit quand j'étais
commissaire européen là ne soyez prudent
avec ça monsieur le député parce que ça
va vite quand même ce genre de choses
notez que le Conseil constitutionnel a
eu un débat là-dessus très clairement et
que bon soyons prudent avec ça donc
n'utilisons pas cette notion trop
rapidement dans le débat public ce qui
gouverne quelle que soit leur tendance
politique sont en général des gens
sincères qui essayent d'être
volontarisme monsieur le député et on
n'est pas forcément insère quand on est
volontariste alors après quand même pour
répondre à monsieur de Courson s'il y
avait 0 8 points de croissance en moins
si on n'était pas 1% mais à 0,2 ce
serait tout de même 0 le point de
déficit en plus et ce serait dix
milliards en plus donc c'est pas
négligeable
d'où l'enjeu quand même à un moment
donné d'avoir un chiffre qui soit un peu
moins peut-être ben oui peut-être ben
non il y a du plus il y a du moins il
faudra quand même atterrir enfin
Monsieur le Député sur la loi de
programmation de finance publique
je ne me permettrai pas contredire
néanmoins quand même il y a quand même
quelque chose qui va nous servir de
référence commune c'est la loi c'est la
loi organique et ce sont les traités et
de ce point de vue là on peut toujours
s'accrocher à des bidules on peut
bidouiller on peut bricoler on peut
estimer que le programme de stabilité
c'est presque pareil qu'une loi de
programmation et dire que la Commission
européenne comme il se trouve que les
règles lorsqu'on suspendues blablabla
mais à un moment il y a les règles et un
traité et là je peux vous en parler pour
avoir été de l'autre côté de la
frontière si j'ose dire et même en
charge de ces sujets à un moment donné
la Commission européenne reprendra ses
règles des nouvelles ou des anciennes et
de toute façon elle aura besoin pour
délivrer des opinions et pour prendre
des décisions sur les financements
européens d'avoir une ancre de finances
publiques ne serait-ce que pour estimer
ce qu'est le sol de structurel alors
évidemment il vaut mieux que les lois de
programmation ne soient pas des tests
des textes inflammables imprécis qu'on
change tout le temps n'apprend pas à
n'importe finances publiques mais quand
même quelque chose qui soit solide pour
constituer une base de prévision pour
les années qui viennent on a besoin
d'une du point de vue européen du point
de vue français
non le problème de stabilité et la loi
de programmation c'est pas la même chose
et la loi organique dit bien que nous
nous devons nous prononcer par rapport à
un objectif de moyen terme qui figure
votre programmation de finance publique
donc alors évidemment comme nous sommes
bon garçon et bonne fin nous essayons
quand même d'ajuster mais ça n'a pas du
tout la même valeur d'où le problème
juridique constitutionnel qui pourrait
se poser un jour en d'autres termes non
je le redis ça c'est pas un sujet de
plaisanterie pour moi on peut pas faire
ça on peut pas faire simple un moment
donné on est rattrapé par la patrouille
je peux pas vous dire quand et par quel
patrouille mais ça va pas
il faudra qu'à un moment donné que ce
soit du point de vue organique du point
de vue juridique du point de vue la
prévisibilité du point de vue européen
ou du point de vue français on est une
loi de programmation sinon
on aura on aura un succès un souci je
peux pas vous dire lequel nous on va
toujours essayer de raisonner on essaye
on fait notre travail de ma mère un plus
bénévolante possible vraiment qu'un bon
état d'esprit mais bon à un moment donné
quand les règles seront rebrancher
et si je continuais le juge l'apprécie
on peut avoir des sujets qui se posent
sérieusement et on ne peut pas dire
juste ça ressemble c'est à peu près
pareil non non la loi organique c'est
loi organique le traité c'est le traités
et dans la loi organique comme dans les
traités il est dit de manière
extrêmement précise que nous avons
besoin de votre programmation de
finances publiques et en l'absence de
celle-ci on a un souci soit par rapport
à au traité soit par rapport à
l'organique et donc à notre Constitution
j'entends quand même que vous savez pas
quel souci quel patrouille et quand
ouais sauf que vous savez c'est comme
l'histoire du type qui tombe du 10e
étage jusqu'à maintenant ça va
bon un moment donné on touche le sol
allez on va arrêter
on passe aux inscrits une minute
orientations supplémentaires Fabien des
Philippot
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président je
salue également le premier président du
Haut Conseil des finances publiques et
ses équipes simplement une question
aujourd'hui on est dans un scénario par
rapport à la réforme des retraites que
nous allons étudier ou en 2030 il y
aurait 13,5 milliards à peu près de
déficit si on ne faisait rien mais ce
scénario je crois est bâti sur une
hypothèse de chômage à 4,5%. ça paraît
peu réaliste ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a
pas vu ça et je voulais savoir si vous
étiez capable d'estimer cette situation
et le trou qu'il y aurait à boucher si
on était sur une hypothèse de chômage
plus réaliste autour de 7 ou 7 et demi
pour cent
merci Philippe lothiou oui c'est le
Président Monsieur le Premier Président
une marque et une question la remarque
sur le projet de programmation des
finances publiques moi on peut pas c'est
pas acceptable de laisser dire ou
sous-entendre qu'il est irresponsable de
ne pas avoir voté cette loi ce qui a
notre sang c'est irresponsable c'est le
gouvernement qui part arrogance a
maintenu des prévisions soit irréalistes
soit inacceptables voilà je voulais le
dire parce que ça c'est comme pas
accepter d'entendre un peu tout et
n'importe quoi sur les retraites je
reviendrai sur les retraites des sujets
en fait la question c'est paraît former
les retraites c'est où trouve-t-on des
sous dans un pays qui étranglé par les
prélèvements obligatoires et par la
dette je pense que le fond du problème
il est là sur place la question et si on
place cette question bon le choix
politique a été et de le faire porter
sur la qualité de vie des Français c'est
un choix nous avons l'occasion d'en
reparler j'ai juste une question on a un
axe assez réducteur ce qu'on parle le
réforme des retraites on va gagner sans
on va gagner ça or cette réforme on sait
très bien qu'elle va faire porter des
dettes des coûts supplémentaires sur
l'origine d'assurance chômage le régime
d'assurance vous voyez la validité les
collectivités territoriales les
départements via le RSA ou les communes
et la MF l'a dit qui vont devoir garder
des gens plus longtemps etc dans un
système assurantiel donc le gain
éventuel d'un côté
quelle est l'impact des charges
complémentaires qu'on va voir des autres
côtés de nombreux autres côtés voilà ce
que je voulais poser comme ça merci
Damien baudet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
monsieur le Président du géo-conseille
je vous cite la réforme des retraites
est nécessaire face à une montagne de
dettes donc il est pour vous nécessaire
de reporter l'âge de départ en bref de
demander à celles et ceux qui ont eu le
pays durant la crise covid les monnaies
grâce à qui on a pu manger les soignants
et les pompiers soigner les aides à
domicile qui sont occupés de nos aînés
d'en faire plus en bref ceux qui nous
ont sauvés pendant la crise covid ce
sont restés aujourd'hui qui nous coûte
presque trop cher Les Essentiels la
seconde ligne et on s'interroge jamais
mais si et on s'interroge jamais sur
ceux qui nous entourent députés
politiques nous-mêmes au salaire et je
vais devoir de vous prendre aussi par
exemple pour exemple entre un salaire de
14000 euros par mois une retraite de
députés français 3000 euros par mois une
retraite de commissaire européen 4000
euros par mois une retraite de 1700
euros par mois chaque mois la France
vous verse 22.000 euros de 60000 euros
par an et je vous pose la question en
tant que kex député ex-ministre ne
voyez-vous ne voyez-vous pas ici un
problème moral sur le fait que ce soit
toujours à nos plus essentiel à ceux qui
font tourner le pays de se serrer la
ceinture en bref à ceux qui galèrent de
faire le sacrifice supplémentaire
merci Michel Castellani
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
premier président vous avez déjà évoqué
évidemment les perspectives moi je
voulais vous demander clairement quand
vous interrogez vos algorithmes est-ce
que vous pensez que la situation de
stagnation qui est très défavorable
commençait au finance publique et donc
la question sur le traitement des
retraites cette situation de stagnation
vous apparaît-elle durable car on voit
sur le slide là le poids d'être public
par rapport au PIB c'est très bien on
sait très bien que tout ça est très
relatif la dette publique déjà c'est un
peu morose elle est à 113% elle était
hausse constante mais il faut la
rapporter à quoi il faut la rapporter au
niveau de taux d'intérêt qui sont
imposés par le marché il faut la
reporter aux données du commerce
extérieur qui est un désastre pour la
France on le sait
il faut le rapporter exactement à ce que
je viens de dire c'est à dire au niveau
de croissance qui est très faible au
rythme d'inflation qui se relance donc
tout ça ça fait une conjoncture qui dans
le monde qu'on puisse dire et qu'elle
est un peu difficile un peu morose ce
conjoncture vous paraît-elle très
durable ou pas je sais que vous avez
déjà évoqué cette question merci merci
et enfin David Amiel
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président dans le débat qui entoure la
question des retraites certains
préconisent des hausses importantes de
prélèvement obligatoire la Cour des
comptes prenait une position forte sur
ce sujet dans une publication d'octobre
2021 intitulé continué à adapter le
système de retraite pour résorber les
déficits et renforcer l'équité en
indiquant je cite que les marges de
manœuvre pour de nouvelles hausses des
taux de cotisation apparaissent
restreinte dès lors que la France a déjà
le taux de prélèvement obligatoire le
plus élevé de l'Union européenne
pouvez-vous dès lors nous préciser quels
effets économiques seraient attendre
dans le cas de hausse importante de
cotisations
merci monsieur le président
sur la première question sur les
prévisions sur le chiffrage du déficit
avec une hypothèse de chômage différente
là c'est pas à nous les choses
s'adressent nous ne sommes pas encore
une fois une instance de prévision c'est
tout à fait le rôle du corps c'est
peut-être vers eux qu'il faut se tourner
je redis vous n'avez peut-être pas
entendu que je ne peux pas mettre jamais
de dire qu'une
de parler de l'irresponsabilité de
parlementaire je ne l'ai pas dit mais je
veux redire ici de la manière la plus
claire qu'une loi de programmation n'est
pas optionnelle qu'elle est obligatoire
et que son absence est un problème grave
pour le pays encore une fois c'est pas
moi de dire de quelle loi il s'agit
c'est à vous Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés avec vos collègues sénateurs de
parvenir à un résultat là-dessus je
crois que c'est très important
avec des mots peut-être différents mais
tout à fait respectueux de ce que vous
êtes je suis obligé de le dire après
vous m'interrogez sur la question des
dépenses publiques et aussi du coup sur
la question des prélèvements
obligatoires et les deux boucles en fait
parce que si nous regardons quand même
la situation dans laquelle nous sommes
en France nous avons quand même quelques
paradoxes qui doivent je pense tous nous
frapper nous sommes des pays de l'Union
européenne celui qui a le niveau de
dépenses publiques le plus élevé
58% nous avons un de ceux nous sommes à
de ceux qui ont le niveau de prélèvement
obligatoire le plus élevé au dessus de
44%
et nous n'avons pas pour autant des
services publics qui donnent total
satisfaction que ce soit dans la
perspection dans la perception dans la
réalité je vais citer deux exemples que
j'utilise assez souvent sur le logement
pour des comptes à produits l'an dernier
une structurel qui manque quand même
qu'on dépense pas loin de deux fois plus
que nous partenaires européens qu'une
efficacité qui n'est pas en réalité
supérieure notamment sur un objectif qui
est très important pour le concitoyen
qui est la construction logement social
autre exemple sur l'éducation nationale
nous avons un système de gluation
nationale qui est massif obligatoire
coûteux et nos performances telles
qu'elles estimées par pizza
sont plutôt faibles en tout cas elle
diminue il y a un problème de ce point
de vue là et on ne peut pas vivre
durablement avec cette situation dans
laquelle on a à la fois des dépenses
plus très élevées qui ne correspondent
pas à une qualité de service public
suffisante avec des prélèvements
obligatoires qui ont forcément leur
limite ça vaut pour la retraite comme
pour le reste et ça fait un certain
temps que je le dis dans cette fonction
comme dans d'autres et donc je n'ai pas
plaidé pour l'augmentation des impôts et
des cotisations pas davantage je le dis
aussi au passage que je n'ai plaidé pour
la baisse des impôts comme nous n'avons
pas les moyens je pense que nous sommes
dans cette situation là toute baisse
supplémentaire d'impôts comme nous avons
un niveau déficit très élevé doit être
compensée soit par une hausse d'autres
impôts soit par une maîtrise de la
dépense du concurrence parce que sinon
nous faisons que creuser le déficit
comme nous l'ont pas de croissance donc
je ferme cette parenthèse
cette situation est hautement
insatisfaisante et c'est la raison pour
laquelle les solutions nous les
connaissons elle s'appelle pour
l'essentiel effectivement l'élévation
notre niveau de croissance potentielle à
travers des politiques d'investissement
qui sont du Mans et intelligemment
ciblés même si c'est du long terme nous
savons que pendant les quelques années
qui viennent il faut pas attendre des
faits miracles sur la croissance et puis
ça s'appelle aussi
la maîtrise de la dépense et j'utilise
le mot maîtrise plus que le mot baisse
parce que en réalité ce qui est en cause
et j'y insiste c'est la qualité de la
dépense publique je suis incapable de
parler de l'éducation en général de la
santé en général parce que que ce soit
dans l'éducation à la santé il y a sans
doute des dépenses supplémentaires à
faire santé on pense tout le monde pense
à l'hôpital et il y a aussi les
économies à faire il est temps que dans
ce pays ne soyons capables de soulever
le capot
des politiques publiques pour aller
chercher ce qui marche ce qui marche pas
ce qui marche pas il y a des économies à
faire et sans doute des renforcement à
faire ce qui marche doit être confortée
et c'est la raison pour laquelle ça fait
des années je le faisais quand j'étais
commissaire européen je le fais
aujourd'hui comme premier Président je
le fais comme président du Conseil
j'appelle à des revues de dépenses
publiques annuels avec de vrais
objectifs avec une vraie méthode une
vraie gouvernance quelque chose de
sérieux nous avons échoué dans divers
exercices sous divers présidents les
sous divers gouvernements là maintenant
il faut vraiment s'y mettre parce que on
est confronté à ça sinon nous risquons
d'avoir une insatisfaction générale par
rapport à ces problèmes encore une fois
beaucoup de dépenses
une efficacité perçue et réelle
insuffisante des prélèvements
obligatoires qui pèsent sur tout le
monde et qui finissent par provoquer
quand même des réactions c'est pas comme
ça que nous devons faire ces raisons par
lesquelles j'ai encore une fois augmenté
le niveau de croissance potentielle et
ça passe par l'investissement nous
soumure d'investissement financés que
j'évoquais et d'autre part faire enfin
l'inventaire de nos dépenses publiques
pour avoir des modifications de
politique publique intelligentes ça
c'est vraiment la solution moderne et je
crois indispensable et c'est une
question qui est à la fois économique
financière sociale politique et
démocratique c'est fondamental et c'est
aussi pour ça j'y reviens c'est quand
même le message que j'ai voulu passer à
plusieurs reprises aujourd'hui que nous
avons besoin d'une loi de programmation
de finances publiques parce que
transparence prévisibilité n'est pas
plus ruelles et je redis très
satisfaction par rapport aux
informations dont nous avons disposé
dont j'ai été obligé de me faire l'écho
devant vous tout ça ça ne fonctionne pas
ça ne tourne pas et nous avons besoin
d'avoir
vraiment des bas de finances publiques
qui vont se payer atteignent un niveau
de maturité de partage avec le Parlement
avec
d'autres acteurs de toute nature et dans
lesquelles nous sommes enfin Monsieur le
Député tous les citoyens doivent
contribuer à la hauteur de leur revenu